hypnosis the son of night and darkness
the brother of dreams and nightmare
secluded in his cave by the sea a silent
an empty place to be we've previously
discussed NYX and some of her children
and today it is another one of those
children that we'll be examining Hypnose
the spirit and personification of sleep
the name Hypnose or hip knots is taken
directly from the Greek word meaning
sleep ignores and as his name would
suggest he was indeed the ancient Greek
version of The Sandman he was also a
twin brother of Thanatos the
personification of death and among his
numerous brothers and sisters with her
honor Roy a collection of deities who
were responsible for bringing dreams
now these began as hypnosis siblings but
many believed that his sons also became
part of the amar I Morpheus the master
of Dreams Feber tall whose name
originates from the Greek word meaning
frightening was responsible for the
creation of nightmares but in some
variations he was instead referred to as
he Geller's and he would make dreams
seem more realistic lastly there was
Fanta sauce whose name derived from the
Greek word million fantasy and he would
be responsible for creative and
fantastical dreaming it was believed
that hypnose resided in an Erebus the
land of eternal darkness who in some
accounts was even considered to be his
father he made his home in a dark cave
blind in opiate blooms such as the opium
poppy and the bread seed poppy now there
is another variation of this cave
located under the island of Lemnos where
the river forgetfulness would flow which
ties into the idea that sleep is a time
when we could forget our problems when
the night did come
Hypno's would rise into the sky with his
mother nyx and bring sleep to all those
below he would eventually take a wife
known as passeth Thea who was the
youngest of all of the Grace's promised
to him by the goddess Hera
Pasi Thea was regarded as the goddess of
meditation relaxation and hallucination
so naturally makes sense that these two
gave birth to children who are heavily
associated with dreaming when Hypnose
was depicted as a physical being he was
seen as a young man with wings on his
shoulders or even on his brow and the
idea of these wings covering his eyes in
all the forensic sleep is quite
interesting
he was often depicted carrying around
several objects that would aid him send
people into a slumber of
horn that contained a sleep-inducing
opium that would cause sleep when blown
a branch dipped in the river of
forgetfulness occasionally an inverted
torch and a poppy stem there aren't many
mentions of hypnosis in greek mythology
but he does play a small run Homer's
Iliad during the Trojan War era wanting
to help the Achaean people and the
forces of Troy seduced her husband Zeus
and had hypnose place him into a deep
slumber
however hypnose wasn't able to keep Zeus
asleep for very long and when he awoke
he was furious
pursuing hypnose endlessly until he fled
to his mother's cave Nix was eventually
able to convince Zeus to forgive her son
and forget their conflict when Hera
witnessed her attempts to help the
children people were largely in vain
because Heracles had sacked the entire
city she blames Luce for his son's
actions and she once again asked hypnose
to play Zeus into a deep slumber
this time hypnose was quite unsure as he
barely escaped the wrath of Zeus on the
previous occasion she was able to
finally convince him by offering empathy
Thea the youngest sister of all of the
graces whom he always wanted to marry so
once again Hypnose play suits to sleep
this time it was for much longer and
would spread to Poseidon who helped the
Achaean people to victory when Zeus lay
sleeping when Zeus eventually awoke he
heard the news that the Trojan War had
been turned in Haris favor but he never
learnt of what Hera and hypnose had done
so now that we've got the bulk of the
video out of the way we can touch upon
some of the cool little facts and
tidbits that I came across the Roman
iteration of hypnose was known as somnus
which is where the English word for
insomnia actually comes from within mean
and not and somnus min and sleep the
word hypnosis is derived from hypnosis
named hypnose million sleep and OSIS
meaning condition and the same can be
said for hypnotic medicine which is
known to induce sleep hypnosis is
definitely an interesting deity who
doesn't really seem to receive much
attention feel free to share any
thoughts ideas you may have on hypnosis
in the comments below and if you haven't
already done so please hit that
notification bill so you never miss an
upload as always I've been your host
mythology in fiction explained
[Music]
you